well so Jane what we've got at the
moment is a huge concentration of assets
uh the sort of things that will be
required both to look for Titan but also
to get it off the bottom if they
actually find it within the time scale
and I think what people are doing is
they're trying to get as much there as
soon as they can to show they're doing
as much as they can just in case it pops
up if we look at the area more closely
as as we've seen these ships are coming
from every direction though mostly from
the north but you've got these
specialist seabed operations and
Recovery vessels all circling the wreck
of the Titanic now they're using
underwater vehicles with side scans
sonars they're using active sauna boys
from the air to actually look for and
classify what might be Titan and coming
down from the north from this morning
onwards are what I think are the game
changers you've got a situation where
these these vessels are coming down
possibly bringing the US Navy's deep
deep Salvage equipment that's the form
of an unmanned vehicle that can go down
to twenty thousand feet it's tethered
and also a salvage system that can bring
up anything up to sixty thousand pounds
from the seabed and they actually did
that successfully with a Seahawk
helicopter in the Philippine Sea in 2021
so it's proven technology they've done
it so if they find Titan they have now
got the means to bring it to the surface
and that's what we've lacked up until
now yeah the priority has been getting
everything there so when there's
information to go on they can mount the
next stage absolutely rescue operation
and let's talk about the sounds that
have been detective and you talk about
you know the vessels on on the sea
looking for the submersible but it's
also being looked for by air and it was
an aircraft that detected these banging
sounds they've been called now the hope
is you know that it is the submersible
people inside banging SOS messages or
whatever
but it's unlikely to be that in your
opinion such as the sort of debris where
they might be it could be anything I
have to say I think just trying to keep
morale up and maintain urgency
um it would have been detected on a son
of boy I suspect dropped by a Canadian
Maritime Patrol aircraft and certainly
you can determine from the frequency uh
difference between various things in the
ocean but let's have a look at what's
going on here you've got a deteriorating
and decaying wreck there's a lot of
things banging around inside Titanic at
the moment if you put your head in the
water right now you'd hear all sorts of
mechanical noises and I'm afraid to say
I think they've got that mixed up if
they were really certain they'd be
zeroing in now and trying to find out
where it's coming from and let's have a
look at this this is a carbon fiber Hull
are you going to take a hammer from the
inside and bang on the the whole no
you're not because it's going to weaken
the hull and of course it will it'll
speed your end if you're not careful so
I'm very skeptical and what we really
need to do is concentrate on where it's
likely to be and you start where it was
going it was going to Titanic it's had
problems in the past where they've
continued with the mission so the
likelihood is it's near Titanic and you
do an expanding Circle search out from
there so let's not get distracted by
things that are most unlikely
um Chris you put it really well earlier
in terms of you know if you're going
down to the Titanic everything needs to
go right and every trip down there
you've got away with it if you come back
to the surface something has clearly
gone wrong here and big questions are
being asked about the safety of not just
this kind of this submersible but other
kinds that make these kind of trips for
for tourist reasons really
yeah I mean it's a question of risk and
reward isn't it but just let's have a
look at what the company says look
bringing an outside entity in other
words Regulators or people who might
actually criticize what we're doing up
to speed on every Innovation before it's
put into real world testing real world
testing which means we take it down to
Titanic it's anathema to Rapid
Innovation so we don't care about safety
we just want to get technology in we're
going to use the stuff and frankly we
don't care what people think about it